Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Alana Newhouse, who's the founder and
editor in chief of Tablet magazine.
We're going to be talking about a term broken
ism, which I think is super interesting.
And it sort of puts a different perspective
on what, you know, maybe Alana in our program
we often see is like a left right political
divide only.
And that's the analysis we make.
And we sort of don't go any further.
You talk about broken ism and status quo ism.
Talk a little bit about how you first thought
of this framework and what you mean by it.
Speaker 2: Sure.
So two years ago, I wrote a piece called Everything
Is Broken.
In it, I tried to articulate what felt to
me like an experience that not only I was
having, but a lot of my readers were having.
A lot of people who I knew were having, which
is the sense that a lot of the institutions
in American life and society that we have
to interact with, whether that's our kids
schools or our health insurance companies
or the IRS, felt like they were not functioning
properly.
They felt broken in the wake of that piece.
I got a tremendous response to it.
It was really incredibly gratifying.
And one of the greatest parts of it was that
I ended up getting emails from a bunch of
people who became regular correspondence with
me.
And one of them became a friend.
And his name is Ryan.
And I talk about this in the beginning of
the follow up essay on Broken ISM, where at
one moment Ryan looked at me and said, I don't
even know what I am.
I don't know if I'm a Republican or a Democrat
or if I'm a liberal or conservative.
All I know is that I believe in your piece,
in the basic premise of your piece, which
is that things feel broken.
And so I guess I believe in broken ism.
And that kind of articulated an idea for me
that I thought was very clarifying because
it felt to me like that actually was the thing
that people believed from all over the spectrum.
And so I tried to write a second piece that
articulated what I thought a brokenness perspective
on the world entailed.
Speaker 1: You know, sometimes when I'll have
a more detailed conversation with folks who
have this general idea that there's a lot
of things that aren't working, but they might
identify as being on the political left or
on the political right.
One of the things I've experienced is that
when you really get details from them about
what are the ways in which some of these systems
aren't working?
And what's your instinct about the solution?
It seems to align much more closely with what
would be considered a left wing view.
Now, that may be my bias and who I'm talking
to, but very often it will be the the revelation
I have that there's a lot of discontent with
many systems, but a lot of people don't seem
to realize that the solutions they are gravitating
towards are actually more aligned with one
side of political spectrum than the other.
And that's sort of like a concern to me that
people aren't acknowledging that.
Do do you experience the same thing when you
talk to some of these folks, or is my view
maybe partial or biased?
Speaker 2: What I think I probably experience
something a little different from you, but
what I guess I would say is, is that one of
the things that people talk to me about is
not only the solutions that they're looking
for, but also the diagnosis of the problem.
And if if in a funny way, if I could say what
I think might be the case, even maybe for
the people that you're talking to.
Yes.
Is that the solutions that they're grasping
for, no matter what part of the spectrum they
come from, ends up being solutions that would
be associated with the left.
But the diagnosis of the problem sounds a
lot like people from the right.
Mm hmm.
And that's also interesting, right?
Because then we can have a conversation that
can be generative where we can say, Oh, okay,
so maybe I come from the left, but I can talk
to somebody from the right because actually
what we could agree on is what's causing some
of these problems.
Even if what we do, even if we disagree on
how we would, what we would do to replace
them.
And that to me, part of the reason why I.
That out.
This different way of seeing things is because
it also I was trying to get people out of
their entrenched teams and get them talking
to each other and finding the the areas of
the landscape on which they might agree.
Speaker 1: One of the things that I've experienced
at the anecdotal personal level when interviewing
former extremists like KKK, neo-Nazi types,
etc., is that they all tell a very similar
story of the circumstances that made them
vulnerable to getting pulled into these movements
in the first place.
And it's a lot of the things that weren't
working.
It was a lot of broken things that that were
going on.
Is this a I mean, not everybody becomes a
KKK member, obviously, or a neo-Nazi, but
there seems to be a radicalizing effect of
a lot of these things that just aren't working
for people.
Is that accurate?
Speaker 2: I think it is.
And I think the people who study extremism
might find overlapping themes or events in
in some of what I write about.
And, you know, it's part of what's a challenge
here is a friend of mine actually wrote and
said, you know, Elena, I sort of agree with
you.
I see what you're saying.
But I mean, come on, is it really mono causal?
What how did all of these institutions get
broken at the same time?
How is that even possible?
So many of them were started at different
times.
And so, of course, the answer is quite clear,
which is technology.
Like, we did have one thing happen.
And if you actually look back to the Industrial
revolution, this exact same thing happened
in society.
When you have an economic revolution that
changes the means of how we live.
It then comprehensively, almost in a cascade,
changes all parts of life.
It changes religion, communication, the postal
Service, it changes everything.
And as a result, we have to adjust.
I think the same thing is happening now.
These institute all of our institutions.
We're faced with the challenge of needing
to embrace and adjust themselves to new technologies.
Some of them adjusted better than others,
and some of them are breaking under the pressure.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Neil Postman wrote quite a bit about this
in his books Technopolis and then also Amusing
Ourselves to Death.
And there's a sort of structural argument
there about, you know, in linguistics there's
this idea it's not I don't know that it's
completely universally accepted, but it's
much explored that the language you speak
actually impacts your worldview to some degree
based both on a combination of syntax and
the culture surrounding it in the vocabulary.
The technologies that we have, including social
media or television or whatever, actually
are deterministic to some degree about what
issues make it into the news media or how
do we approach problems or whatever the case
may be.
It's that sort of argument that would explain
the timing, I think, of what you're talking
about.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Absolutely.
Speaker 1: So Neil Postman would say there's
really no going back.
And it's about how do you try to regulate
in order to harness the parts we want, but
to limit the parts that don't work so well.
When we think about solutions, do you agree
with that?
Speaker 2: Yes, I think that part of that,
you know, in this interview, I've talked a
lot about the brokenness perspective, but
part of what I tried to do with the essay
was also articulate the other perspective,
the sort of Warren perspective, which I also
find incredibly compelling, which is the belief
in what's what exists and the belief that
what exists may or may not need some reforming
or need some tweaking, but that you simply
don't throw whole institutions or systems
out the window, especially when those systems
are.
Ah, the the basket for people's needs sometimes
and their safety and their livelihoods.
The status quo is believe that we need to
work very, very hard at fixing our current
institutions.
In a way.
There's a I think, an incredibly inspiring
and exciting conversation to be had if you
put those two groups together.
Because what you get is you say, Oh, how about
instead of fighting?
And trying to convince each other to join
sides.
We're not going to join.
What if together we look at the landscape
and we almost assess like, do it, do an assessment
and say, what are the institutions that need
reforming?
What are the institutions that need radical
reforming and what are the institutions that
need complete replacement?
And let everyone do their part.
Let the brokenness look at something and say,
This is broken.
I'm burning it to the grounds and I'm starting
again and let the status quo ists reform what
might actually be salvageable.
Speaker 1: The difficulty in that, as great
as it sounds, is that there is a big divide
about what's worthy of totally being destroyed
and starting from scratch and what needs to
be reformed.
You mentioned education.
Last week in a 48 hour period, you had Candace
Owens saying the solution to the U.S. being
poor at math is breeding for math skills like
the South Koreans do.
And then two days later at CPAC, she says
we should get rid of the Department of Education.
It's like you don't need to breed, you need
to teach.
We.
But they want to.
But on the left, I think we would not say
we need to get rid of the Department of Education.
So it seems that the disagreement would come
in, which of which institutions fall under
which of the two categories.
Speaker 2: So you're you're right.
And look, the if the people that you're trying
to create conversation with are people who
are political rhetoric, missions, that's a
challenge.
It's very different from my own right.
I'm actually looking to create to generate
a conversation that feels fruitful among.
Regular people, okay?
People who actually are maybe people who belong
to the same town.
Right.
But who feel differently about the solutions
or differently about the institutions of their
world.
And they're invested at a personal and granular
level in those institutions.
And they are not grand standers who are just
looking to make broad points.
These are people who actually want to get
their hands dirty.
They just don't know in what way.
They don't know if they're if they want to
get their hands dirty by.
Completely abandoning their local school district.
Because it's become too corrupt.
Right.
Or by reforming it, getting different people
on the board.
And those are to me, those are decisions that
actually do have to get made at the local
level and do have to get made person by person,
town by town, community by community.
And then I think it generates friends nationally
and maybe even internationally.
Speaker 1: Super, super interesting.
We've been speaking with Alana Newhouse, who's
the founder and editor in chief of Tablet
magazine.
And we'll link to the articles that we've
been sort of talking about in this conversation.
Alana, really appreciate your time and insights.
Speaker 2: Thanks so much for having me.